hey guys like many of you we're
sheltering in place in fact we're even
separated from each other while Julia
awaits the results of her kovat test
thankfully I'm feeling much better but I
don't want to get Phillip or the baby
sick but we know that people are looking
for financial info more than ever so
we're gonna do this lo-fi and try to
answer some of the pressing questions on
top of people's minds starting with the
stock market crash so I'm gonna let
Phillip handle this one and keep getting
rest but I will be back next week
remember way back in February 2020 the
good old days
stock markets at all-time highs everyone
had a job all the toilet paper you could
ever want life was great the US stock
market measured by the Dow has fallen
over 35 percent in a month's time wiping
away years of growth we witnessed the
worst single day decline since 1987 and
the exchanges were temporarily shut down
three times in a week when it fell too
far in a single day when the stock
market fell by more than 20% we
officially entered a bear market bear
markets usually but not always precede a
recession like the stock market crashes
preceding the Great Depression of 1929
or the Great Recession of 2008 depending
on the criteria there have been between
10 and 20 bear markets in the last
century and this month we just entered
another one this is a scary time we're
living in right now I'm the first to
admit it I was worried when Julia came
down with a bad cough and how to get
tested for Coke in nineteen I'm hurting
for my friends and family who are
experiencing layoffs slowdowns and
closures this will have a lasting
harmful effect on our economy and many
people's lives but what we're seeing
right now in the markets is not
unprecedented in the words of investing
pioneer Sir John Templeton the four most
expensive words in the English language
are this time it's different
we always think the current crisis is
unique world wars
nuclear meltdowns great depressions even
the global Spanish
pandemic that left 50 million dead the
stock market's long-term average is
accounting for every one of those
terrible times every time things seem
hopeless
every time markets recover the bear
wanders back into the woods and the
markets thrive again it will happen with
coronavirus and the other bears in our
future to selling out of stock
investments when a bear market rears its
head turns a bad situation into a worse
situation in two big ways first you
realize the loss turning a decline in
share value into a real loss in your
bank account think of it like seeing
your home appraised for less and
immediately putting it up for sale you'd
never do that second you're making
nearly certain that you miss the
recovery when it happens between 1993
and 2013 the sp500 grew by 9.2 percent
annually but if you take out just the
ten best trading days over that period
your annual average is cut nearly in
half if you missed the 60 best trading
days you'd averaged a negative four
point three nine percent return by
jumping out after a bear arrives you
seriously risk missing the wave of the
recovery now the aggressive among you
may be wondering well is now the time to
buy stocks maybe but with a few caveats
financial experts discourage investing
in the stock market with any money you
may need sooner than 10 years from now
keep money for short-term needs in safe
havens like cash bonds and CDs but if
you have a nice cash cushion and you
were already planning to invest that
money anyway yes go ahead and continue
to invest into the market by investing
in good times and bad you get to take
advantage of dollar cost averaging a
strategy that by investing on a regular
basis allows you to buy more shares on
the cheap and less shares as they get
expensive investing is for the long term
retirement or college accounts are
designed to be invested and grow for
decades
don't let the term
news of today make you rethink a solid
long term strategy that big mean bear
will eventually wander back home and
you'll be glad you kept your cool and
didn't make him mad and that's my two
cents
[Music]
you